We all experience emotionally charged
conflicts,
whether it's in the workplace with a
colleague,
whether it's at home with a spouse,
whether it's even in our country,
dealing with political issues,
the challenges,
how do we deal with them most
effectively.
Now,
my sense is that most people come in
with like the quick fix answer,
uh,
the rational approaches just listen a
little bit more,
talk a little bit less,
and that's useful,
but that's not enough.
Beneath rationality is this other layer
to the conflict,
which is the emotional layer.
You're starting to get angry.
You're colleague is starting to get
angry and things start to fester,
but even that is not the fundamental
force driving us in conflict.
What's the core?
It's identity.
At the end of the day,
what tends to fuel our emotions in a
conflict is a threat.
Who we are and what we stand for,
and the moment I threaten what you
deeply care about,
all of a sudden now we have a real
emotionally charged conflict.
So the moment your identity feels
threatened,
all of a sudden you fall prey to a very
dangerous mindset that I call the tribes
effect.
This is an US versus them mindset.
You could be in a conflict with somebody
you love your mother,
your kid,
but the moment you get into this
mindset,
it becomes me versus you,
US versus them.
Think about a conflict in your own life.
There are three basic characteristics to
this tribal mentality.
One,
it's adversarial.
It is me versus you to it's self
righteous.
I believe I am right and legitimate in
my perspective and I believe you are
wrong and crazy and element number
three,
this tribes effect.
It is a closed system,
so I will argue and defend my
perspective to no ends,
but I am going to close my ears to your
perspective.
This is the tribes effect.
We fall into it in the family dynamic
and unfortunately just as true national
dynamics,
international dynamics,
we see the polarizations there.
Once you attach to a tribe,
something strange happens.
No longer is content as important.
The substance of the arguments,
the the policies that is important,
but at the end of the day,
the most important element in terms of
being a part of a tribe is loyalty,
loyalty to the tribe,
and the most serious offense that you
can commit against your own tribe is to
betray that tribe's trust.
It's loyalty.
It's essence.
It's to go against the tribe in some
way.
You look at the United States now,
they're these huge political divides.
You see the democratic tribe or tribes.
You see the Republican tribes as well,
and it's very difficult for either side
to even say,
I understand what you're saying because
some on the inside of each side are
going to say,
oh,
nope.
They're betraying our tribe,
and the moment betraying the tribe,
that's a taboo.
If I break a taboo,
I can suffer social punishments.
I'm going to be excommunicated.
I'm going to be ridiculed or worse.
That's the challenge of our tribalistic
world that we're in right now.
So you can have somebody in Trumpville
or Clintonville who,
uh,
you know,
totally is getting hammered by.
Well,
let's say in the trump world,
because totally going to get hammered by
the by,
it changes to healthcare,
but they're still in that camp because
they're part of the tribe.
Recognizing that identity is critical.
It sort of opens our eyes to what might
be going on in the world around us and
our communities around us.
Think about some of let's think about
some of the issues that are in the
public sphere,
abortion,
healthcare,
taxes,
security of the country.
All of these issues hit right to the
core of our identity,
who we are and what we stand for.
And the moment I feel that any of those
elements is threatened now I moved
toward the tribes effect.
Now I want to move toward being with a
group of people like myself who are
going to protect me and my interests
from becoming trampled on.
And a powerful tool you can do is to
emphasize the US,
the two of us,
you know,
moving from ego to we go,
there we go.
And it's a big difference watching
conflict situations.
I've noticed something interesting,
you know,
at first people are battling it out,
my perspective versus yours and all of
the energy is moving toward my ego and
my perspective versus your ego and your
perspectives.
When you start to see the transition,
what starts to happen is that each side
recognizes there's also an us,
there's me and there's you,
but there's also the space between us
that we are creating together and the
more you can emphasize the US,
the more you can move toward real
reconciliation or the two of you moving
together towards some cooperative and
sustainable outcome.
I mean,
looking at the rhetoric in the United
States right now,
there's so much divisive rhetoric.
Where are the voices of us,
the United States of America,
and the more you get those kinds of
voices,
the more you can start to,
in a sense,
overpower the US versus them thinking.
We're not trying to overpower.
The idea is that the people have behind
their us versus them thinking.
We're trying to overpower that
adversarial mindset.
Mm.